when I started hosting marijuana was
illegal and you can smoke cigarettes any
place you wanted I believe he did the
greatest monologue ever and I think it
was because of his political sensibility
and the worst thing about losing this
job I'm no longer cover NBC I'd have to
sign up for Obamacare after 22 years as
the host of The Tonight Show Jay Leno
said goodbye to late night though he was
no favorite of TV critics Leno held the
top ratings spot for over two decades
after succeeding the legendary Johnny
Carson recent TV sat down with longtime
Leno producer Dave Berg author of the
book behind the curtain an insider's
look at Jay Leno's Tonight Show to
discuss lenez legacy of elevating
politics and late-night talk Johnny
Carson who of course is a legend the
greatest there ever was he set the bar
very high for all of us
however Johnnie emphasized entertainers
on his show I'm not saying he didn't
have politico's from time to time he did
but the emphasis was on entertainers
well the strategy that we used to kind
of expand and maybe get better ratings
was to move beyond entertainers and I
think that this is what distinguished
Jay not only in the guests that he chose
I mean basically we had every major
presidential candidate from 1996 on but
also in his monologue which he expanded
it from Johnnie's with seven minutes and
Jay expanded his to 14 minutes and added
a lot of political humor he set the pace
I believe he did the greatest monologue
ever and I think it was because of his
political Sensibility you talked about
having presidential candidates the you
guys were actually the first to get a
sitting president when you had President
Obama on can you talk a little bit about
the story of how that happened
five years before he became president I
was watching him speak at the Democratic
convention in Boston and that was in
2004 Kerry was the the Democratic
candidate that year and and I had never
heard of this unknown political Illinois
and I thought oh my gosh this guy is the
best speak
I have seen since Ronald Reagan I'm not
talking politics here I'm just talking
about the ability to communicate and I
was very impressed and the next day I
started calling on his people to express
an interest in getting him on the show
now we did finally land him on the show
as as an author the the audacity of
hope' when he was a presidential
candidate so when he did finally agree
to appear as a president he had already
been on he had already had a trust yet
and it kind of a chemistry with Jay but
nevertheless when he decided to appear
on the show on his 59th day in office
that was amazing because no other
president had ever appeared on a
late-night show it was actually
considered unpresidential that was a
huge moment and you know looking back at
that why do you think it took so long
for that to happen I mean do you think
that politicians are kind of afraid of
going on platforms like that because
they're afraid of being made fun of I do
and as I always told the political
people actually we're much easier
I'm not saying Jay didn't ask tough
questions he did he certainly did
but we weren't Meet the Press and Jays
attitude about guests is he believed
that that it was a family environment at
the Tonight Show and and he actually
acted as though guests were like guests
in his house so he always said I'm not
going to throw you a curve ball you
don't have to worry I'm I will ask you a
tough question I'll ask you this I'll
ask you that but he never never asked
gotcha questions so we were actually
easier than Meet the Press it never
seemed like he was really accepted among
you know the comedic elite and here he
is now he's going to get the Mark Twain
humor award at the Kennedy Center this
fall what do you think is so
misunderstood about his success I think
that the critics the Television Critics
basically
early on starting when Jay took over
from Johnny Carson early on they said
this guy doesn't have the chops he
doesn't have what Johnny Carson has and
by the way he's not cut from the same
fabric as David Letterman
it is so much more edgy and they are the
ones that basically set the tone for for
how J was perceived among if I may use
the word among elitist not among the
folks who live in the flyover States
those wonderful flyover States but among
the elitist who felt that J's humor was
much too milquetoast
actually I think J's approach was was
exactly what it should be what you want
to do is you want to tell jokes that
appeal to a broad band of viewers we
weren't narrowcasting we were trying to
reach a wide group of people and I think
J did that very successfully and I think
the Mark Twain award is justification
finally J gets the credit that he
deserves and a lot of people you know
would always try to tie a political
label to him but you know because we
have more of a libertarian audience do
you think kind of that independent
streak that he was more working-class he
worked really hard I know you talked a
lot about his work ethic in the book do
you think that kind of came through the
fact that he was just a little bit more
independent and that's maybe why he
broke through to such a larger audience
I definitely do and again I think you
could see it in his monologue jokes I
think that resonated with people I
really do the fact is in the last you
know two three years none of the other
late night hosts were doing Obama jokes
well Jay felt well J happens to like
President Obama but his feeling was you
got to go after who's ever in power and
he alone was doing jokes about Obama for
a long time finally when Obamacare you
know became the disaster that it was at
least for a while the other host started
following soon do you think that his
willingness cuz I see it now with Kimmel
yeah and a little bit with Fallon and
Letterman they've kind of followed suit
but do you think that that is kind of
one of his main legacies as far as you
know being an equal opportunity offender
oh my gosh yes I mean I really think
that distinguishes him and and yes if I
understand your question properly there
doesn't seem to be a healthy skepticism
of those in power and that concerns me
because
late night is so influential especially
among younger people I think yeah and
you know there's also kind of this I
guess you can call it a PC movement
going on where you've seen a lot of
comedians lately having to you know
apologize for jokes do you how do you
think that affects the material right or
did it really come into play when he was
crafting his monologue that was a big
problem and I have to say that among the
the comedy writers and comedians whether
they were liberal a conservative they
hate PC they do not like political
correctness because that restricts them
in their job and that was very damaging
and it hurt a lot of jokes we had to
sort of water down some of the jokes
everybody did and and I think everyone
suffers as a result you're you're
missing SATA you're missing good satire
when you look at who's out there now you
have Kimmel you have Letterman as
stepping down you have Colbert coming in
now and now you have Jimmy Fallon who do
you see kind of emerging as as that
standard bearer of being the top dog I
actually am a Jimmy Fallon guy and I
like Jimmy Kimmel they're both really
good I watched them both but Jimmy
Fallon when he took over for Jay
honestly I did not want to like him I
didn't like the fact that Jay was you
know being let go when he was doing so
well but when I started watching a
Fallon on a regular basis he won me over
and I like him because he continues with
that really positive upbeat attitude
that that Jay represented and he has
brought kind of a new perspective he has
redefined late-night on his own terms
now it's about comedy bits
it's about performance the guests get
involved they want to get involved Jimmy
gets involved because he's so talented
and he has done very well I would go so
far as to call him the king of
late-night he's going to be the guy to
be that's my feeling